welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with this the weather parts of
East Texas are under flash flood
emergencies right now as tropical
depression in Melda drops the most rain
on the region since Hurricane harvey the
storm spawned multiple tornadoes east of
Houston yesterday several homes were
damaged torrential rainfall flooded
roads and made driving dangerous along
the Gulf Coast people are being urged to
shelter in place imelda has already
dumped more than a foot of rain in
Houston and more than two feet in parts
of East Texas one town saw a half foot
of rain in just one hour
Janet Chamberlain is in Beaumont Texas
where rescues are underway Janet what's
the scene there now Toni good morning
this is life-threatening flash flooding
I am using the iPhone because we are
literally stranded in our hotel no one
can get in or out
several feet of water just outside the
entrance to the hotel let me give you a
look a mile away where our crew is
located they are also stranded in their
hotel you can see the cars there with
water up to the tires it has been a
deluge all night long
a deluge in Southeast Texas cars sinking
in floodwaters and stranding drivers
relentless driving rain in the town of
winning forestry slim healthcare a
hospital and nursing home to evacuate
this is the power of tropical depression
imelda the rain accompanied by
thunderstorms lightning and tornado
warnings in Baytown about 25 miles east
of Houston
some drivers risked going through the
rising flash flood waters during rush
hour horn is down
others drove to a tornado in Highlands
Texas the twister crossed a road in the
path of trees power lines and cars some
homeowners are already starting the
cleanup of downed tree limbs and debris
from roofs coastal areas experienced
some of the worst of the storm it was
shaking it was just very loud rumbling
and just it was lightening up in the
community of Sargent along the Texas
coast almost 20 inches of rain has
fallen this week more is expected the
rain isn't stopping anytime soon we
might get another 80% chance of rainfall
so if we get that on top of this there's
a chance we're gonna experience some
more flooding again Janet shamlian
reporting from Beaumont this is a live
look now at the hotel where her crew is
staying as you can see the water is
creeping into the lobby there nope
everybody stays safe